heads up nick fury's calling you
i don't really want to talk to nicholas
why because if you don't talk to him and
i have to talk i want to talk to him
you sent nick fury to voicemail i gotta
go you do not ghost nick fury
welcome to your weekly ticket
well it looks like mia de costa is set
to direct the sequel to captain marvel
captain marvel 2
set to hit theaters july 8 2022 the
first captain marvel was a huge success
and was directed by anna bowden and ryan
fleck
and megan mcdonald will script the
sequel lionsgate has just confirmed john
wick
five keep him coming the sequel will be
shot back to back with john
wick 4 which is expected to shoot next
year
john wick 4 is set to open in theaters
on may 27
2022 and a release date for the fifth
has not yet been announced
chad stalsky will return to direct both
films
and garth davis has been tapped to
direct disney's third tron movie that's
in development with jared leto set to
star
the original 1982 film starring jeff
bridges was set inside a computer
program a cyberspace called the grid
where a computer hacker is abducted and
forced to participate in gladiatorial
games
the film received mixed reviews but
returned with the sequel tron legacy in
2010.
leto will produce in addition to
starring in the film
no word yet on if dat punk is returning
to do the soundtrack
but if they don't who do you think
should make it i'm genuinely curious
let's face it we could all use a
vacation right now and while some of us
may not be able to physically take one
we can always look to film to take us on
some epic trips
that's why today we are booking our
movie vacation
through fandango now's list of epic
travel films
and today's special guest is journalist
podcaster and
comic enthusiast karama karma
what would you say is your pick from
this travel list which one's your
favorite
hey there um my favorite is
actually spiderman far from home now i'm
not gonna say that it's my favorite
spider-man movie
but it's one of my favorite travel
movies because
they went all over europe and i have not
i know i should have done this before we
all got locked down and quarantined but
i have not traveled to europe
they went to um prague and berlin and
london
and italy that the plaza they were in
in venice st mark square i want to take
pictures there like they did
i want to go to the da vinci museum it's
just
everything every location they were at
in this movie
made me want to travel and in fact after
the movie i actually picked up this
um crazy book marvel put out actually a
travel book how apropos right
peter and ned's ultimate travel journal
and it was written by preethi tipper and
it's
so much fun it literally takes you back
through all the places that they visited
so i just think that's the ultimate
travel
uh movie for me has any film made you
want to
travel to a place after you saw it in a
film
it's funny i thought lord of the rings
all of them were
gorgeous um but it wasn't until i got a
chance
to visit new zealand i actually got a
chance to visit the um
elita battle angel set down there what a
digital that i
really fell in love like i was this
close to losing my passport because i
wanted to stay there so badly
oh man going to new zealand sounds
pretty good it's
gorgeous or literally anywhere right
yeah
right now yes any place outside of my
house would be lovely
don't test me i'll leave the door's
right there
what about if you were stuck a place is
there any movie location that you would
be
okay with that if you ended up getting
stuck there
yeah wakanda yeah i'll go now you can
leave me in wakanda
right now just leave me right by the
border tribe
i will hang out with wikkavi and all of
his crew
i yeah just when do we leave and that's
a good place to like if you just want to
disappear too like if i just wanted to
get out of here there you go winter
soldier did it for what two movies like
just chopping wood
all right well thank you so much carama
if you want to follow her on any of her
social media it's at
the blurred girl bye thanks a lot
and if you're looking for some other
recommendations from our travel list
here are a few suggestions
you will live a long time have many
friends
many experiences you will lose
all your money don't worry you will get
it all back
again and you will come back to bali
and then i will teach you everything
i know liz gilbert played by julia
roberts thought she had
everything she wanted in life a home a
husband and a successful career
now that she's newly divorced and facing
a turning point she finds that she's
confused about what's
important to her daring a step out of
her own comfort zone liz embarks on a
quest of self-discovery
that takes her to italy india and bali
the film which is directed by ryan
murphy is also about to celebrate its
10-year
anniversary and also available to watch
at home from our list
is american honey it's a business
opportunity
we go door-to-door we sell magazines we
explore like
america we party come with us
you got anybody who's going to miss you
not really
okay good you're hired star played by
sasha lane
is an adolescent girl from a troubled
home who runs away with a traveling
sales crew that drives across the
american midwest
selling subscriptions door to door
finding her feet in this gang of
teenagers one of which is jake played by
shia labeouf
she soon gets into the group's lifestyle
of hard partying nights
law bending days and young love all
right well that's it for today but check
out that full list of travel films in
the link below
and let us know which one is your
favorite i'm kale and i'll see you next
[Music]
time
[Music]
you